the first people you see are your
parents yeah so so you had told me once
that you started out doing impressions
of your parents yes that's who your
who's in your lawyer my father
Oh who taught this is my Bessemer you
talk like this oh geez you couldn't show
any weakness around my dad like you say
I can't find my car keys oh Jesus Christ
I always know where my car keys are I
keep them in my pocket the last time I
talked politics with I mean this was a
quote I can't talk politics with you
because you don't know [ __ ]
[Laughter]
my parents got very excited when I had
success they were very [ __ ] my mother
it's like you sure got a lot of fans out
there and my dad you know he was after a
while he but first was he a little like
dismissive because sometimes it's it
might be tough if your dad was putting
you down all the time and then suddenly
you're successful how did he help well
yeah I mean he well initially it was
like I he said oh Jesus Christ comedian
you're never make it as a comedian and
then after I did do well he had his arm
around me I always believed in him hey
Dad I stubbed my toe
I never stubbed my toe because I lift my
foot right before stomach